♪ ♪
>> WE HAVE WON AGAINST ISIS.
WE HAVE BEATEN THEM AND WE BEAT
THEM BADLY.
>> THE CALIPHATE HAS CRUMBLED
AND ISIS HAS BEEN DEFEATED.
>> I HOPE THE PRESIDENT LOOKS
HARD TO MAKE LONG AND HARD.
>> IN NORTHERN SYRIA, FOUR
AMERICANS WERE KILLED AND TWO
SERVICE MEMBERS AND TWO
CIVILIANS.
THERE IS A LOT OF TALK ABOUT
SYRIA POLICY IN THE WAKE OF
THIS.
MEETING WITH EDITORS AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, ONE OF THEM
RAND PAUL RELEASED A STATEMENT
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE AFTER HIS
MEETING.
"I'VE NEVER BEEN PROUDER HOW
DONALD TRUMP.
HE STOOD UP FOR A STRONG
AMERICAN TO MAKE AMERICA A
DEPOSED FOREIGN WARS.
PUTTING AMERICA FIRST MEANS
DECLARING VICTORY IN AFGHANISTAN
AND SYRIA.
"LET'S DISCUSS ALL OF US
TONIGHT.
THE FOX NEWS NATIONAL SECURITY
AND FOREIGN AFFAIRS ANALYST,
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
YOU HEARD SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM
SAY BECAUSE OF THE ANNOUNCEMENT
OF THE WITHDRAWAL OF TROOPS THAT
THAT WAS ENTHUSIASM, A SPARK HE
THOUGHT FOR ENEMIES.
DO YOU BUY THAT?
>> I DO, BUT I ADD MORE, THAT IS
EXACTLY WHAT ISIS WOULD DO.
ONCE THEY REALIZE WE ARE ABOUT
TO DECIDE -- GO TO CONVINCE US
TO WITHDRAW FASTER.
IT IS A GAME BETWEEN TURKEY AND
THE KURDS.
THAT IS WHERE THE REAL GAME IS.
TURKEY HAS A SECURITY PLAN THAT
THEY WANT TO APPLY MOVING INTO
KURDISH AREAS.
THAT IS IT NOT EXACTLY WHAT WE
WANT TO SEE.
WE WANT TO SEE A SEPARATION.
WHAT IS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IS
THAT ISIS UNDERSTANDS AND IS
TRYING TO SPREAD CHAOS.
>> Bret: THIS PRESIDENT SHOULD
GET CREDIT, FROM 2017 UNTIL NOW.
THERE HAS BEEN IN OPERATION IN
THE LAST TWO WEEKS TO TAKE OUT
THAT REMAINING ISIS PART, THE
PRESIDENT TWEETING "I SPOKE WITH
PRESIDENT ERDOGAN TO SPEAK ON
WHERE WE STAND IN ALL THESE
MATTERS.
20-MILE SAFE SOUND, WE SPOKE
ABOUT ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENTS
BETWEEN THE U.S. AND TURKEY.
GREAT POTENTIAL."
AS THEIR CONFIDENCE THAT TURKEY
WILL NOT MOVE IN AND WIPE OUT
THE KURDS?
>> THE GOVERNMENT ARE SAYING
VERY CLEARLY, THEY CONSIDER OUR
EYELASHES AS TERRORISTS.
THEY WANT TO MOVE IN THIS
DISMANTLED THAT'S OWN.
THEY WANT TO BRING IN THEIR OWN
MILITIA IN THAT WAY THEY DEFEND
THEMSELVES.
THAT MEANS THAT THEY'LL BE AT
WAR WITH THE KURDS.
WE ARE NOT EVEN PRESENT THERE.
THEY CAN BE A DANGER FOR
THEMSELVES.
THE IDEAL SITUATION IS TO
SEPARATE BOTH FORCES.
>> Bret: SEMI ALLIES -- CALLED
LAST THING HERE, THEY ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE ALMOST 800
FIGHTERS WHO BEEN CAPTURED IN
SYRIA BEING HELD BY SYRIAN
DEFENSE FORCES, OVERLOOKED BY
U.S. TROOPS.
IF U.S. TROOPS LEAVE, ALL OF
THOSE FOREIGN FIGHTERS WILL
SOMEHOW BE LET GO INTO THE WIND.
>> THAT IS SERIOUSLY A BIG
PROBLEM IN MY SOURCES INSIDE THE
KURDISH AREA TOLD ME AS OF TODAY
THAT THEY ARE CONSIDERING TWO
THINGS.
NUMBER ONE, CONNECTING WITH THE
REGIME AND HAVING THEIR ARMY
DEPLOYED ACROSS THE BORDER.
WITH TURKEY THAT WOULD BE TO OUR
ADVANTAGE --
NOT TO OUR ADVANTAGE.